alright guys eSports orgs and late
payments name a more iconic duo
unfortunately this kind of thing still
happens all the time
even in 2020 if you thought the dark
days of orgs failing to pay their
players and staff and feeding them
excuse after excuse for doing so we're
over well I got one for you this is a
story about a pretty small org there was
some pretty big money ok guys before we
get start with the actual story I really
want to quickly say I know we deal with
a lot of negative stories here on don't
have me and I do think it's important to
shed light on those however I also think
it's important to celebrate what we love
about eSports and to that end we've got
an award show that's right the score you
Sports Awards is going down on YouTube
Wednesday January 15 be there all right
on with the story now if you've never
heard of an organization called loki
esports well i can't really be that
shocked but look even if the name
doesn't ring a bell
they actually have or had a lot going on
they've got a pub G team Dragon Ball Z
fighters players Rainbow six teams csgo
teams they had an overwatch contenders
team they had a league of Legends squad
that made it to worlds and a rocket
League team that made it to the rocket
League World Championships so that all
sounds pretty good right well hold on
according to multiple sources I have
inside Loki eSports and documents
supplied to me
this organization owes their players and
staff more than a hundred and thirty
seven thousand dollars in late payments
and fees this huge chunk of money is for
everything from Rainbow six siege player
salaries in Brazil to Jersey design fees
in Canada now according to both players
and members of staff at Loki eSports
that I talked to this whole problem
started around October of 2019 now prior
to that Loki eSports seemed to have been
more or less okay with getting their
payments and on time any delays would be
measured in days or weeks at the most
but starting in fall of 2019 those
delays started to be measured in months
months of Unruh sieved payments and
broken promises to rectify the situation
for example one of my sources provided
me
various screenshots of conversations
that happened between Loki eSports
former eSports director and various
regional managers and I have similar
screenshots of similar conversations
with other members of the corporate
staff of Loki eSports as well for
example for the head of the Canadian
division of Loki eSports mera Davis this
issue has stretched back all the way to
December 1st and she says she's heard 10
to 15 different broken promises that
she'll get the money that her region is
owed each one thus far obviously has not
been fulfilled
now Mira was only hired in November and
she submitted her first budget to the
org on December 1st which basically
means she's been working for these guys
for two months and hasn't seen a dime
but other people who have been with the
or longer have been waiting longer for
their payments I also spoke to Enzo
Toledo aka tantor he's a member of that
rocket League team that made it to
worlds for Loki and he told me that he
and his team haven't seen a dime in the
entirety of November and December to say
nothing of January and that includes a
trip to Madrid with expenses for the our
LCS season 8 finals
this guy's team made it to Worlds and if
he's not getting paid that's not a good
sign then for example there's Joe El
Prado aka romp he is a pub G mobile
player signed to Loki eSports and he
says he hasn't been paid at all since
signing on with the team at the very end
of October he also confirmed to me that
no other players that he's aware of have
received any payment in the last several
months oh and if Mira Robb tantor and
all the other people at Loki actually do
get paid out it's gonna be their last
paycheck from Loki eSports yeah that's
right
according to multiple sources I spoke to
for this report On January 7th Loki
management informed almost all the
regional managers that their regions
would be shutting down for good that's
every region apparently except for the
Philippines Vietnam and Sri Lanka some
of those sources also provided me with
screenshots of conversations that
corroborate this and that is what seems
to be happening at this point
Loki's website their Twitter their
Facebook their Instagram it's all wiped
clean from the internet now no one I
spoke to for this story be they players
or management
had any clear explanation for why their
regions were being shut down and why
there was such a huge delay in payment
beyond simply well we ran out of money
also no one I spoke to was given formal
notice of their termination with any
kind of letter the screenshots of
conversations I've been provided with
when it comes to this issue have all
been extremely vague with language like
we're not going to continue or everyone
is just going to shut their doors
according to both players and management
I spoke to they were fed stories about
anything from banking errors to PayPal
issues to prepaid cards getting stuck in
customs to cryptocurrency apps they
wanted to use that didn't work in some
sources including Victor Lewis he's the
Brazilian team manager for Loki eSports
even told me that they were told that
part or all of the company was going
bankrupt now that last part is
interesting because I have two different
sources who at this time will remain
anonymous in order to protect them from
reprisals who provided me with contracts
from Loki eSports now in those contracts
one of the grounds for termination was
bankruptcy or insolvency of the company
now if the company is indeed going
literally bankrupt in the legal sense
then I have some questions like what
about the partnership with Dell that
they recently announced why were they
hiring managers recruiting players and
opening an entire new region as late as
November how could so many regions close
or go bankrupt when certain others which
presumably are part of the same company
could remain open the public reaction
from now former Loki employees regarding
the impending closure of so many regions
was not great the same day I was told
that everyone the company was told they
were being let go for example the
regional manager for North America
tweeted about backstabbing and false
idols rompe that pub G mobile player I
talked about earlier tweeted that it had
been two months since he or his team had
been paid and two months since he'd
heard anything from the owners he also
used the hashtag pay Loki romp also had
some pretty pointed accusations for a
guy named Max now that's max wood the
former eSports director for Loki eSports
this is the same max you've seen in
screenshots provided by my sources the
same guy who's been relaying promise
after promise about repayment schedules
to all of Loki's
Regional Managers over the last few
months now max as I said was formerly
the eSports director for the org and
from what I understand has been
operating as the single point of contact
between the regional managers and the
people who actually owned and run low
key eSports principally this seems to be
a woman named Rama lean Penta for see
apparently the regional managers and
definitely the players very rarely if
ever interact with this person and the
other owners and operators of low key
eSports it's always this Maxx guy acting
as a filter in a mouthpiece between the
two parties now I did speak with max for
this story and he told me that a he no
longer works for low-key eSports and V
he is continuing to act as a liaison
between the people who need to get paid
and the people who hopefully have the
money out of a show of good faith
because he feels somewhat guilty
somewhat responsible for what's happened
I did of course also reach out to the
owners and the executives of the org and
one of them Tony look nuyen did respond
he's listed as the co-owner of low key
community on social media and he told me
that he primarily handles marketing for
the low key divisions that aren't
eSports as for what exactly low key
community is and how it's different from
low key eSports well it's official
website describes it as a gaming
platform but I don't know it to me it
just looks like a clothing brand they
appear to have some kind of deal with
Filipino boxer Romero dunno and there's
like pictures of him hanging out with
Manny Pacquiao while wearing low key
gear it's all very weird anyways
regarding the eSports side of things he
told me quote all players and staff will
be paid within two weeks this has been
communicated with everyone the players
have every right to be angry but
thankfully we are fixing everything end
quote
Danny you basically told me that
everything was all good with the players
and staff and that they had been
informed for the reason of their delayed
payments when I asked him what that
reason was he never responded to me
again and just to reiterate at this
point guys not a single person that I
spoke to for this story was ever given
any clear reason for the delayed
payments or the closure now there are a
ton of loose ends to the story as well
loose ends like how certain players told
me they were being denied bonuses or
transfer fees that they had negotiated
prior to Loki letting them go loose ends
like is the sudden and rather
casual termination of so many people's
contracts even legal I am looking into
these issues and more and I am
consulting with lawyers about it in the
meantime as I said earlier we have yet
another promise from low-key esports
corporate side that all outstanding
money will be repaid within a short
timeframe and pretty shortly we'll know
if it's an empty one or not and if it is
well you're gonna see me here again
pretty soon I hope you don't
it's kotor he doesn't know what Knights
of the Old Republic is where who are
these people yeah it came out in like
2004 like I actually don't have a brick
laptop I have like a high-end laptop I
don't have a PC like I don't have a
tower at home I specifically bought or
super thin super small high-end good
processor laptop because I want to be
able to travel with it do whatever I
want to do so I can play eSports games
on it like I can play like dota League
whatever it can handle shitty games like
that I am an graphically I didn't mean
there's shitty games I meant lit
graphically